foreign
to this the annual meeting of the
council may I first remind you of a few
domestic Arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs cold water is
also available in the breakout area
outside the meeting room if the fire
alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by the following the fire
exit signs and meet on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you're told
it's safe to do so please switch off all
mobile phones or turn them to silent
I'd like to remind anyone in present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where they
are confidential or exempt items if you
make a representation to the meeting you
will be deemed by the council to have
consented to beam filmed by entering the
meeting you are also consenting to being
filmed by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully excluded
so um
right thank you everyone I'd I'd just
like to make a short speech
um as the outgoing chairman um
[Applause]
so um
the Suffolk District Council the um the
officers and the public
as we sit in the
um chamber today at the end of an
eventful year I'm deeply humbled to
stand before you as chairman of
mid-suffolk District Council for a few
more seconds
the year has been a memorable Journey
For Me filled with challenges and
wonderful moments that will be forever
etched in my memory
first and foremost I'd like to express
my heartfelt gratitude to the previous
representatives of the council many of
whom are no longer serving I'd like to
thank that previous year's Council for
their unwavering support during my
tenure
we have accomplished so much and I'm
immensely proud of what we've achieved
together
the officers as well especially Jan and
Karen I don't know where Karen is there
um thank you so much for your incredible
support and these personal meetings that
made sure everything went to plan
so um also I'd like to thank my wife
bryony who's been incredible we started
this this year
Chairman's year with a two-year-old
daughter and a team of old son and so
it's been an incredible time in my life
but I've been so well supported in that
way I tried to attend as much of the as
many of the events as a family as
possible so we've had nappies being
changed in the mayor's parlor we've had
um children falling asleep in cars only
to wake up in a procession with a brass
band in it and um there's I do remember
actually making a um doing a reading in
a church with my daughter on my shoulder
her turning her head Looking Over the
Sea of Faces or listening and then very
quickly burying it again in the safety
of my of my jacket
but I'm a Brownie's support has been
absolutely fantastic in this year to
balance that for us to balance that
child care and this position
so one of the great things about being
chairman of mid-suffolk is you get to um
choose a Chairman's charity to spend
time with and raise fundraise for I
chose stowmarket ASD Saturday clubs we
managed to raise 4 400 pounds in that
year with um several events and I think
that's a real Testament to the
generosity of the community
the um I hope these funds will be really
useful to carry on the great work
they're doing and help continue
transferring the transforming the lives
of um lots of young people with Autism
Spectrum Disorder providing them with
support and resources to help them these
wonderful young people's thrive
it's it's I really am grateful to that
charity for their support and everyone
that contributed to it
so um it was quite an eventful period as
chairman we had the historic event it
was very sad um passing of her majesty
Queen Elizabeth II the longest reigning
monarch in British history and this was
the real moment of profound sadness for
the nation we we mourned a remarkable
leader and her Duty will always be
remembered but also at the same time
there's great joy with the coronation of
King Charles III
and he will continue the noble
Traditions that Define the monarchy for
centuries it is a really good time to
embrace the future with optimism and
determination and we look forward to the
reign of the new monarch
but with the end of this speech I'd also
um and and the end of my M term I'd also
like to welcome councilor War boys to
the chair he's I think he's going to
make an absolutely fantastic chairman
and it's a pleasure to pass the chain
onto him I'm filled with immense pride
and gratitude to have sat in this chair
it is an honor to serve the people of
mid-suffolk and work alongside dedicated
council members and witness people
coming together for their Community
these councilors leave a lasting Legacy
reminding us the boundless potential
that we possess when we all work
together and thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you
so the first item is the election of the
chair of the council
please could I have the nominations for
the position of chair of the councilor
Council
councilman
yeah thank you Mr chairman I would like
to propose councilor Roland War boys
as chair of the council
I've known Roland uh for quite a long
time principally because he taught all
three of my children out at Stockbridge
High School I hope you've recovered
but in all seriousness I believe
councilor War boys carries a certain
gravitas
a mantle of years and an authority which
befits the role of chairman of the
council for which she's ideally suited
and I'm happy to propose him
thank you very much councilman and could
I have a second uh councilor e Byrne
it's very much chair I'd be happy to
Second Council of War boys and look
forward to working with him thank you
okay thank you
are there any further nominations
no so we'll um will carry out a show of
hands all those in favor please
the war boys Julie elected as chairman
of mid-suffolk District
[Applause]
okay
I Roland wall boys having been elected
to the office of chair of the council
hereby declare that I take that office
upon myself I will duly and Faithfully
fulfill the duties of it according to
the best of my judgment and ability
I undertake to be guided by the Suffolk
local code of conduct in the performance
of my functions in that office
first of all
I'd like to thank the citizens of
gisling and Ward for re-electing me in
May to represent them on the
mid-sufficient District Council
secondly I'd like to thank my fellow
counselors for elector mayor's chairman
on behalf of the council's past and
present I would like to thank
the outgoing chairman James Caston for
his Exemplar chairmanship over the last
year his fundraising for his chosen
charity and hope to match his fair
courteous and sympathetic approach
I'd like to take this opportunity to
welcome all the incoming counselors
those re-elected and also the many new
councilors who are here for the first
time
finally I'd like to thank on behalf of
the council in their Awards all those
councilors who have not returned this
year to serve as counselors especially
those of many years experience
in particular Council pennyotten 29
years Council Mike Norris 24 years
Council Tim pasma 20 years Council Kathy
Guthrie 16 years and Council John Field
16 years
my two chosen Charities this year are
Street Forge sternum Magna and Beyond
the war also based in Thorne and Magna
both these Charities work with people
from the age of 16 who have a disability
they are focused on removing barriers
through tuition and guidance
to enable people using their services to
achieve their potential for Rich and
meaningful life
over the coming year the vice chairman
and myself will be looking to raise the
awareness of young people in Prime and
high schools of the work of Midsouth
Council
the district councils and Parish
councils
I hope to encourage engagement with the
Democratic process and prepare them to
take up their roles as young citizens
we would also be working to encourage
participants participation in Holiday
activity and fruit programs across the
district
and also developed the conservation
volunteer scheme where young people work
with our baber amid Suffolk seasonal
Rangers and give them the opportunity to
raise the awareness of the human and
environmental challenges facing society
and the confidence to meet them
thank you I'd like now
to move to item two on the agenda
election the vice chair of the council
may I have nominations please for vice
chair
councilman
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
propose councilor Daniel Pratt to be
Vice chair of the council Dan brings a
wealth of experience and knowledge to
the council and in terms of his skills
for this role
as a teacher he is used to handling a
room full of difficult characters so I'm
sure he will do very well as Vice chair
to support you
thank you
thank you councilor huben
be very happy to
um second counselor Dan Pratt for the
control of Vice chair thank you thank
you Kelsey but are there any further
nominations
I intend to carry out this vote by show
fans
I therefore declare counselor duly
elected
[Applause]
I Dan Pratt having been elected to the
office of Vice chair of the council
hereby declare that I take the office
upon myself and will duly and Faithfully
fulfill the duties of it according to
the best of my judgment and ability I
undertake to be guided by the Suffolk
local code of conducts in the
performance of my functions in office
I just want to thank the residents of
basford and ringshaw for re-electing me
to represent them at mid-suffolk
District Council
and my fellow counselors for electing me
to the position of Vice chair
following the chair's announcements I'm
really looking forward to working with
the chair and our experts in local
government to promote local democracy
with our youth in schools colleges and
sixth form centers across the district
thank you
apologies for absence
Declaration of Interest by councilors
are there any Declarations of Interest
I'd like now to refer to mc231 to
confirm the minutes of the meeting held
on 20th of March 2023 for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
could I have a proposal please
Council Matheson
could have a second
councilor Whitehead and
and tend to carry out this vote by show
of hands all those in favor
um Chairman's announcers I refer you to
paper mc232 that refers to the previous
chairs announcements and is to be noted
election of leader of the council may
have nominations pleased for leader of
the council
Council Stringer
thank you chairman and congratulations
for your new role I would like to
propose councilor Andrew Millen for the
position of leader of the council thank
you
Council
thank you chair I'd be extremely happy
to Second councilor Mellon for the role
of leader of the council thank you thank
you councilman any further nominations
please vote by show of hands
councilman duly elected
[Applause]
could I have the latest announcements
please
chairman um can I buy the first to
congratulate you on your elevation to
your new position as chair of the
council and also to councilor Pratt
as Vice chair I'm sure you would both do
a very good job over the next year and I
commend you for your choice of Charities
to fundraise for and also very grateful
that you've both agreed to Champion the
Democracy project
with 20 new members on the council you
do have a job of work to do in learning
the new names and faces but I'm sure you
will soon know your counselor married
from your counselor Morgan your Davis
from your Davies and your headingham
from your hardingham
but I would like to start by welcoming
all members to this new Council term
where the newly electeds or returning
for another four years
each of you have put yourself forward
you've made it through the campaign and
have been elected to represent your
community and every one of you has a
significant contribution to make to the
work of this Authority
I'm also sure we all want to thank our
hard-working officers for the smooth
operation of the election count at
worsted Park I know that this required a
big team effort not just from the
elections team but with many other staff
members in support and with the
significant media interest it was a long
and busy day so thank you to Arthur and
all the other staff involved for a job
well done
I would also like
to as we've heard several long-serving
members stood down at this election and
we will miss their wisdom and experience
and I'm sure that all members will join
me in Wishing them a long and happy
retirement
I also want to thank the three
councilors who served in the last term
who the check who the electorate chose
not to return here due to this sometimes
brutal business that we call democracy
councilor Tim Passmore the counselor for
20 years former leader here and who
still has a big job as our police and
crime commissioner
councilor Harry Richardson who's talent
I feel sure will carry him back onto the
political stage at some point
and I must also pay tribute to the
council's leader for the last four years
councilor Susie Morley who on a hung
Council pulled off the remarkable
achievement of leading a stable
Administration for four years I wish her
well for the future and I'm sure she
will be back
having looked back I now want to look
forward and briefly set out our
administration's priorities and program
for the next four years
we have an emphatic mandate from the
electorate to deliver a sensible green
agenda that we set out during the
campaign
now mid-suffolk's residents are rightly
concerned about a variety of issues
the cost of living perhaps the foremost
among them this this past year
for many it is finding an affordable
place to live
and that others spoke to us about the
provision of local services or public
transport or the decline of town centers
and above all these concerns is the
looming threats from climate change
which we can no longer speak of as
something in the future
it's here and now
last week the milk the World
Meteorological organization warned that
we are about to cross that 1.5 degrees
warming barrier and we only need to
think back to last summer when we saw
record temperatures in a prolonged
period of drought here
maybe a taste of things to come
and of course alongside the climate
crisis we often but often with a lower
profile is a biodiversity crisis with
huge declines in the populations of
insects pollinators birds and other
wildlife
now clearly a district council such as
ours cannot solve all these problems but
we can make a start
and we can work with others
can take a lead and I believe we can
make a difference
so today we formally press reset the
reset button on the council's priorities
and in the days weeks and months ahead
we will refocus the work of this Council
in a Greener and more sustainable
Direction
now we must continue to deliver the
council services to the highest possible
standard whether that's emptying the
recycling bins
licensing a taxi deciding a planning
application or the 1001 other things
that this organization does so well
we have an excellent team of over 500
staff shared with baber and we want them
to continue to take pride in the work
they do and the services that they
deliver
the world for the climate and for nature
must be at the heart of all that we do
it must be the prism through which we
view every future decision it must run
through this organization like letters
through a stick of Rock
now this Council declared a climate
emergency back in July 2019 here in this
chamber and declared a biodiversity
emergency a few months later
we are to take these declarations
seriously we must take environmental
concerns into account in every decision
that we make
how we work
what we invest in the kind of houses
the locations we choose to allow to
develop and the type of businesses that
we support and encourage and all the
services that we provide
so alongside this reset of our
priorities there are three words that I
want to mention which I think help to
sum up the first green administration's
approach
firstly we must do all we can to improve
the livability of our communities
now this might be a new word for some
people so what do I mean by this
you may have heard of the concept of the
15-minute neighborhood in cities
where all essential Services can be
found within a short walk or a cycle
ride of where you live now we can't hope
to achieve that in in our rural area but
we can look look to promote the
livability of our Villages and towns
supporting the provision of key
facilities which help to make places
easier to live in what some people have
called the foundation economy now this
might be the local pub which also hosts
the Village post office or host of food
bank and those two examples are already
happening in this District
it could be the Redundant farm buildings
repurposed as a microbrewery or or a
business center
or the Village Hall which acts as a hub
for community life
kind of small businesses and Community
connections are often what make
neighborhoods work on on which people
Depend and we want to build those up and
support them
the second word is resilience resilience
is what sometimes sometimes is being
called as bounce back ability
the ability to take a punch and recover
and survive and keep going
now we've seen a number of shocks over
the past year Financial economic
the cost of living and our resilience is
being tested
and our households and our communities
will need to be even more resilient in
the years ahead
there will be troubles for sure some of
which like climate change we can foresee
others which we we're not able to
anticipate
but if we can build up the resilience of
our district we will be in a much better
state
to withstand them
the third words came into my mind just a
little bit too late I was asked by a
journalist last week what will a green
LED District look like after four years
and I produced an answer of sorts but
later I realized I could have just
summed it up in one word and that word
is thriving
we want to see Midsouth thriving
not just economically but that's
important but also culturally socially
environmentally sustainably thriving
and with our focus on sustainability and
Community we want this District to be a
great place to live which it already is
a great place to work to do business and
a great place to visit and if we can
achieve that as counselors as officers
and working with all the other
organizations involved that will be
something to be proud of
so to put these priorities into action
I'd now like to introduce the members of
the cabinet
serving as Deputy lead at the council
and portfolio holder for Financial
Resources will be councilor Rachel Eber
the cabinet member for Heritage planning
and infrastructure is councilor Andrew
Stringer
the cabinet member for housing and
property is councilor Richard winch
Cabinet member for thriving towns and
Rural communities is counselor Teresa
Davis
and the cabinet member for environment
culture and well-being is counselor Tim
Weller
and as leader I will look after the
portfolio for performance and resilience
now whilst the cabinet will lead and
guide our initiatives as I said earlier
I believe that all elective members have
a significant part to play in the
council's work
and there are many ways that this will
be done and whilst we may not always
agree politically it's a good and
healthy thing to have different views
and perspectives and I look forward to
the contribution each one of you will
make
now in that Spirit we've decided not to
nominate green councilors for all of the
committee chair and vice chair positions
sharing those positions with
non-administration members
and this information has been shared
with the other group leaders
and lastly
the last four years showed us that the
leader in cabinet model whilst having
certain benefits is not a particularly
democratic system where half the council
can be denied a state in the
administration
so despite the fact that we have a clear
majority I can announce today that we
will seek within this Council term to
review the council's governance
structure with the intention of bringing
in a more democratic configuration
so Mr chairman in conclusion and I'm
sorry I went on so long I want to I want
to harness the enthusiasm and commitment
of this new Administration and set
ourselves the challenge of being a
fairer more open more sustainable
Council leading to a thriving and
resilient District
foreign
[Applause]
I believe councilor Whitehead you'd like
to have a few words
[Music]
and welcome to your new role
Crystal Mellon as the new leader of the
council
a very interesting speech on which for
me to take away and think about
it's fair to say that the election was a
humbling experience for the
conservatives locally
many seats were lost elsewhere in
Suffolk and indeed over a thousand
Nationwide so clearly it was much bigger
than mid-suffolk but I can understand
though why the spotlight is presently on
Mid Suffolk even though green party's
success here they pulled off a
resounding result
my group will obviously approach the
election result from the perspective
this was the residence of mid-suffolk
exercising the Democratic right they
have every four years to vote for
whomever they want
that right is something we must respect
and cherish
now opposition will be a whole new
learning experience for both myself and
this small group of six conservative
councilors
opposition plays an important role in
the Democratic process
we will approach it with humility
but with a clear desire to hold these
new controllers of the council to
account
the greens have inherited a golden
Legacy from us a council that could
freeze its council tax precept for two
years yet still bring forward a number
of exciting new initiatives whilst
adding to Reserves
and a final budget and four-year Outlook
which covers the whole duration of this
new Council term forecasted budget
Services throughout despite an ambitious
spending program
I should also add that in Gateway 14 and
with our cifco investments we have
created a legacy to last a generation
never mind four years
the greens now take on this future for
that golden Legacy and we will closely
scrutinize how they perform that
stewardship thank you very much Mr
chairman
thank you
all right we now just move on to
designation of committees and joint
committees
uh to appoint the following committees
and joint committees overview and
scrutiny committee planning committee
Licensing and Regulatory committee joint
audit and standards committee
joint appointments committee
could I have a proposal please to
appoint all the Committees listed on the
agenda councilor Miller
that that motion that uh the adoption of
those committees and in a I'll look to
the other side of the chamber for a
second thank you
Council Whitehead
I tend to carry out this vote by show of
hands
all those in favor
I'd now like to refer you to appendices
A and B in the table papers
and I would like to invite fifty Ali
monitoring officer to introduce paper
mc233
thank you chair and very briefly
um sections 15 to 17 of the love of
Housing Act 1989
um require a council to
um secure political balance on its
various committees and subcommittees
um political groups for the purposes of
the ACT
um should not be confused with political
parties the formula for determining the
entitlement of the seats is uh it's
complicated but the number of seats and
the main rule being committees allocated
to a political group must bear the same
relationship to the total membership of
the council
um
thank you uh could I have a proposal
please
councilman thank you chair happy to
propose
thank you could I have a second but
please
um council's got home
thank you I'm sorry second
are there any questions on this
I intend to carry out this vote by show
of hands
in favor
that's his carriage
right election of chairs and vice chairs
of committees note there's in accordance
with the council's Constitution the
leader shall take up chair of the
cabinet
uh to elect a chair and vice chair for
the following committees
overview and scrutiny committee
planning committee Licensing and
Regulatory committee
and to elect a co-chair for the
following joint committees joint audit
and standards committee joint
appointments committee
may I have nominations please for the
chair of overview and scrutiny committee
councilweighted
[Music]
James as
spent considerable time on scrutiny
including carrying out the role of
um Vice chair under Council llewellyn's
previous chairmanship and I think we'll
do an excellent job thank you
foreign
I'm happy to Second Council Castor
Castor thank you Council are there any
further nominations
could have a show of hands please all
those in favor
councilor Caston is Julia Penn pointed
chair of overview and scrutiny committee
may I have nominations please for the
vice chair of overview and scrutiny
committee
could I have a proposal please
[Music]
could have a second to please
Council captain
I'm happy to second
counselor scarf is vice chair of
scrutiny
are there any further nominations
um
could have a show of hands please
that is carried cancer scarf is duly
appointed Vice chair of overview and
scrutiny committee
may I have nominations please for the
chair of planning committee
councilman Mellon
yeah thank you chair I'd like to propose
councilor Sarah mansource chair
he's a very experienced member of
planning committee and I think she did a
great job
councilor Stringer
a chair I would like to second that
are there any further nominations
could have a show of hands please all
those in favor
Council Mansell is duly appointed chair
of planning committee
may I have nominations please for vice
chair planning committee
Council whitening
ham as Vice chair of planning and can I
just take the opportunity to thank the
greens for their gracious
offer of the chair and vice chair
positions they've given us and yes
councilor headingham has had wealth
experience on planning including being
Vice chair in the past and I am through
the confidence and she'll do a great job
thank you
could have a second to please
Council custom
thank you very much I'm very happy to um
second counselor had his vice chair of
planning
could have a show of hands please
dollars in favor
Julie Carrick councilor headingham
is uh appointed Vice chair of planning
right may I have nominations please for
chair
of Licensing and regulator committee
councilman
thank you chair I
would like counselor Oliver Walters for
the chair of Licensing a regulatory
committee
could I have a second look please
councilman
chair I'm happy to Second councilor
Walters as chair of Licensing regulatory
do I have any further nominations
all those in favor please could I have a
show of hands
that's Julie Caron councilor Walters is
duly appointed chair of the Licensing
and Regulatory committee
may I have nominations please for the
vice chair of Licensing and regulator
committee
councilor scarf
thank you Jack can I nominate Council
Wilshire please
uh could I have a second though please
uh are there any further nominations
uh could I carry this out by a voter
shovhans please all those in favor
counselor wilshere is duly appointed uh
Vice chair of Licensing and Regulatory
committee
um
they have nominations please the
co-chair of joint audit and standards
committee could have a proposal please
Council Mellon
thank you chair I'd like to propose
councilor John Mathison for this chair
thank you could have a second though
please
Council Walters
thank you chair um I'd like to Second uh
John Madison for this role
are there any further nominations
uh could I have a show of hands please
all those in favor
that is duly carried Council Matheson is
Julie pointed coacher joint audit and
standards committee
may I have nominations please for
co-chair of joint appointments committee
we have a proposal please councilman
uh thank you chair I'd like to propose
councilor Mellon as the chair of joint
appointments committee
thank you uh could I have a second
uh councilor Carter I'm hiding you Jeff
I'm happy to second thank you
bye sure fans please all those in favor
that's carried councilman Julie pointed
co-chair of joint appointments committee
appointments to outside bodies for 23
24.
[Applause]
I refer you to appendix a in the table
papers I would like to invite the leader
to introduce paper
mc234 and move the recommendation in the
report
thank you Mr chair
um it's been a bit of a job working out
who should do what on all these
different uh
outside bodies I think we've pretty much
got there in terms of the list one
change I do need to make verbally is
that the Western Suffolk Community
safety partnership councilor Carter has
agreed to be the the council's
representative on there
but we have a good set of
Representatives in that paper so I'm
happy to propose that we accept
those names for that for that
not wrong okay thank you councilman
could I have a second to please
Council Caston
thank you Council Cass I intend to carry
this out as well by a voted show fans
please all those in favor
that is carried
mc235 appointment of directors to the
board of msdc Suffolk Holdings Limited
I'd like to invite councilman to
introduce paper mc235 and to move the
recommendation in the report
councilors to stand as directors on
Meetup Holdings which is gives oversight
to the other companies that we have and
that's an important role so the four
counselors that we have put forward in
the paper councilor Matheson
um
counselor winch
councilor lay and
councilor Davies thank you for reminding
me I'm not having a bit paid for in
front of me but I'm sure those four with
a rich number of sort of years of
experience and different experiences uh
we'll we'll provide some very useful
oversight to the holding company
um so I'd like to propose that those
names are accepted as directors thank
you councilman could I have a second but
please
councilor even
thank you chair I'll be very happy to
Second thank you thank you Kelsey but
could I carry this vote out please bro
show fans all those in favor
that's Carrie thank you
appointment at councils for the shared
revenues partnership joint committee the
nominations have been tabled could I
have a proposal please
councilman
thank you chair I'm happy
to propose that we accept the names
which have been
so put I have a second please councilor
stringer at happy to Second chair
uh could I have a show of hands please
all those in favor
that is carried
appointments to the Suffolk joint
Standards Board the nominations have
been tabled could have a proposal please
councilman
thank you chair
um this is an important role when things
go wrong and we need to look into
different cases both in this Council and
other neighboring councils and I'm happy
that those names that are tabled are the
right nominees for this for this board
so I'm happy to propose that
thank you councilman could have a second
to please
Council prep
thank you I'll carry this out by show of
hands all those in favor
that is caring
appointments The Joint Gypsy and
travelers Steering group the council is
Astor point four councilors to the Joint
Gypsy and traveler Steering group
the nominations have been tabled please
could I have a proposer
councilor Mellon
thank you chair again uh happy to
propose that the names which have been
tabled are accepted
could have a second please
I do apologize councilor
Council today of course so thank you
chair
um happy to Second both nominations
thank you Council Layton I'd like to
carry this out via the show of hands all
those in favor
that is carried
appointments the council working groups
Arif
I know no long page
council is asked to point counselors to
the following working groups
Community governance review working
group Constitution working group member
Learning and Development development
working group local plan working group
these placings have been tabled could
have a proposal please
councilman
we'll post the the tabled placings with
one Amendment if that's okay
would like to in the community
governance review working group remove
councilor miles Rowe and replace them
with councilor Janet Pearson
apart from that no other changes and I'd
like to propose that those are accepted
thank you could I have a second to
please
Council staff thank you I'd be happy
names for either any of those uh to date
so I'm pleased to announce that I'm
proposing councilor Adrian Marriott for
the community governance review working
group myself for the Constitution
working group councilor Nikki will share
for the member Learning and Development
working group and councilor Terry
Lawrence for the local plan working
group and I think you then have
thank you Carl thank you counselors do
you accept those amendments councilman
uh could ask for a show events please
all those in favor
that is carried
now just like to note the date of the
next meeting is Thursday the 22nd of
June 2023 at 5 30 pm
and before the meeting closes I'd like
to invite everyone to the annual Council
presentations which are being held
downstairs in the Frink room
the meeting is now closed at 18 19 hours
thank you